it's exciting times for Disney fans as
it's finally been confirmed who will be
playing all the main parts in the
star-studded remake of Disney's animated
classic The Lion King when it hits the
big screen in 2019 yippee K we be lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I'm
going to run through all the details of
the voice cast who'll be playing the
much-loved Lion King characters in
director Jon Favreau's new take on the
1994 hit movie between his critically
acclaimed TV show Atlanta playing a
young Lando Calrissian in the Han Solo
movie and starring a Simba in the Lion
King the Emmy award-winning Donald
Glover is on fire right now and frankly
I just can't wait for him to be king in
Disney's iconic musical speaking of
music in the animated movie Matthew
Broderick only provided Simba speaking
voice but didn't perform his songs
I'm sure Glover will make a tremendous
new Simba and he certainly won't have
any trouble in the singing department
either on the subject of singing non
other than Beyonce is going to be
lending her voice to the adult Nala yes
after turning down the role of the
feather-duster plumet in the live-action
beauty in the beast film the modern
Queen of Pop is taking on a more
suitable role as the queen of the pride
lands now in the original animated movie
adult Nala and her mate Simba don't
actually have that much to do when it
comes to belting out songs but since the
remake has cast two talented singers in
those roles I think we'll see the range
of songs expanded from the classics
written by Elton John and Tim Rice for
the original movie after all that's what
they did in Bill Condon's recent version
of Beauty and the Beast and given
Beyonce uncle Eva's musical leanings I
wouldn't be surprised if they'll have
something of a hand in that themselves
it's fantastic to see James Earl Jones
aka the voice of Darth Vader returning
to the role of Simba's father Mufasa
after he first lent his vocal talents to
the character in the animated movie with
Jones's incredible voice and powerful
style I can't think of anyone better to
play the role the man is a legend given
that the brilliant British actor
chiwetel ejiofor has been cast as scar
and assuming that this version of
Simba's uncle will be continuing the
long Hollywood tradition of villainous
characters with English accents just as
Jeremy Irons did back when he voiced the
role in the original animation
and if you're wondering where you've
seen Ejiofor previously he gave an
oscar-nominated performance in 12 years
a slave and most recently he also
starred in Marvel's Doctor Strange now I
just can't wait to hear his take on scar
speaking of British actors I presume
that talk-show host John Oliver will be
hanging on to his English accent when he
takes on the role of Zazu the same way
that Rowan Atkinson did when he lent his
voice to the animated character in 1994
the last movies were Oliver did some
voice acting were the Smurfs movies
which were pretty terrible so he's got
nowhere to go but up
by the way interestingly enough Oliver
previously starred in the TV comedy
community alongside the new voice of
Simba himself Donald Glover if you're
wondering who will be taking on the role
of mufasa's wife and Simba's mother
Surabhi it's alfre woodard who's given
fantastic performances most recently as
a corrupt council woman mariah Dillard
in Marvel's Luke Cage and there's a
fearful aunt Josephine and Netflix is a
series of unfortunate events South
African actor and playwright John canny
is taking on the role of Rafiki who
teaches Simba some valuable lessons in
the film like many of the Lion King cast
you'll have seen cannae most recently in
the MCU where he played the Black
Panthers father King to Chaka in Captain
America Civil War given how comedic the
characters Pumbaa and Timon are Disney
has wisely chosen to go with two comic
actors for the new film star of knocked
up Seth Rogen will be playing warthog
Pumbaa but this certainly isn't Rogen's
first voice acting gig is he's already
lent his vocal stylings to the Kung Fu
Panda movies as well as the more adult
animation sausage party meanwhile Billy
Eichner who's best known for his work on
the comedy shows difficult people Parks
and Rec and Billy on the street is
taking on the role of the wisecracking
meerkat Timon first brought to life by
Nathan Lane back in 1994 I've got to say
I'm kind of interested to see what Seth
Rogen and Billy Eichner version of
Hakuna Matata will be like there are
loads of Marvel connections between the
actors in this movie and Florence
kizomba is no exception in the Lion King
she'll be playing the hyena shanssey who
was originally voiced by Whoopi Goldberg
but if you've watched Captain America
Civil War then you'll have seen kizomba
faceoff with Black Widow as one of Black
Panthers elite female bodyguards that
or mulashi and she'll be back in that
role in 2018 in the black panther solo
movie comic actors keegan-michael key
and Eric Andre best known for their
respective TV series key and Peele and
the Eric Andre show complete the movies
trio of hyena characters in the animated
movie the other two hyenas were known as
Banzai and aired but their names have
been given a makeover for the new film
with ki and Andres characters being
called Kumari
and Azizi voicing the young Simba Anala
a relative newcomers JD McCrory who was
a handful of TV credits to his name and
shahad II write Joseph who appeared in
the TV musical Hairspray live I'm sure
Disney will have done as good a job
casting these important roles as they
did with other recent films such as
Moana and I've got my fingers crossed
that being part of the Lion King cast
brings great things for these two new
young actors now who's your favorite
character from The Lion King and how
excited are you about the new cast I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this hit
that subscribe button and turn on your
notifications for loads more videos
about Disney and animated movies also
you can check out the links below for
other videos you might like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers